for two days even Martinez has been
living on the streets of Buenos Aires he
and other family members set up a camp
right in front of the Argentine Congress
to demand a food emergency plan to help
the poor the situation is dire for all
of us I'm a construction worker but
there is no work it's difficult to feed
my children that's why I come here
because the president's policies are
slowly killing us
thousands of people took over the center
of one aside is on Thursday when the
lower chamber met to pass a food
emergency plan to cope with the ongoing
economic crisis in the country the law
was first passed in 2002 right after the
economic collapse in Argentina now it's
been extended once again October's
presidential election but these people
say that they've come here to request
government help to help them cope with a
double-digit inflation rate in Argentina
that makes it difficult for them to eat
every day
Ricardo Enrique's is a congressman for
the ruling coalition he says the
government has been trying to help those
in lifted taxes from basic food items
increased a minimum wage increased cash
handouts and lots of other things to
help those who need it I don't
understand why people continue to
protest because we are giving them what
they need Argentina has been in a
recession since last year and has one of
the highest inflation rates in the world
running at more than 54 percent this
month in an attempt to prevent the loss
of foreign reserves the government
implemented new restrictions on currency
transactions so now that you have
capital controls I think that you see
that some degree of stability or at
least have calm tense calm one could say
has come to the to the markets and and
things will be stabilized it remains to
be seen at the end of the day today how
many reserves the central bank actually
sold to maintain the exchange rates but
I think with the with the controls in
place demand for dollars should somewhat
go down or should that you should see
some calm in that area at least for the
time being
Argentina's economy is unlikely to
reactivate anytime soon the crisis is
having a dip impact among those who need
help the most
Teresa Waugh al Jazeera bono Cyrus